[Music]
we're staying at a hotel
at Universal Studios so it's really
weird getting off of the subway and like
seeing everything it says like welcome
to Hollywood Universal CityWalk of Osaka
and I'm like whoa that's weird we had
this at home it's like we're back at
home yeah so we said goodbye to everyone
we had breakfast at the hotel with a few
people and then we took the train with
David Mariel Anna
Jeremy June and Dan and we finally said
our fill well it was funny because we
kept saying goodbye but then we didn't
realize we were still in the same train
for like the next train and then the
next train we're like bye oh wait bye oh
wait it's funny we kept we kept doing I
McLovin or McLovin what was his name
like Michael Cera well that's me that's
the actor's name anyway we kept doing
that thing where you're saying goodbye
but you're still walking in the same
direction it was really funny but anyway
we're staying at this hotel and it's so
fancy like this hotel
makes me feel that like I'm in a movie
set and it's kind of cool because they
gave us all pajamas so they had like a
spa but they actually gave us some legit
pajamas like these are nicer than the
ones we had in the previous hotel cuz
the waffle pattern left a waffle pattern
in my back it was like Game of Thrones
clothes it was one question though are
you happy to be in this again or oh yeah
how is it having your own room that was
so lonely was it yeah
nightmare nightmares so it's a bad
experience would you want another hotel
room all to yourself again are you
getting really like that I mean if you
had a choice you know would you like
your own hotel room to do this well can
you be like this ya know your own room
baby not your own bed yeah cuz this room
is actually the first room that we're
getting our own bed like each person has
our own bed this is really nice yeah
that was whack no way we couldn't fit a
baby in that I mean I guess we could but
that would be very unsafe because you
need to create a border for that kid we
can stick the baby in here actually yeah
we are an Osaka
look at that looks beautiful
yeah I'm kind of sad we had to say
goodbye to everybody yeah do you miss
everyone already you know
do you miss taiko and Leia mm-hmm I
didn't even get to say goodbye
I know Bart yeah oh did you see him or
no I know we didn't get to say a proper
goodbye to Barton geo and taiko cuz they
left super early yeah but it's okay
we'll see them at home but you know
what's awesome we are going to Korea for
a whole week
after the next two days keep making
noises and I'm like what's happening
behind me yeah look at that bathtub you
know it's my favorite thing about Japan
every single toilet including the
airplane has of a day that's my favorite
it's a we happy yeah in the airplane
there was a bidet oh yeah check it out
on our way back oh wait we're not flying
the same airline you're flying
yeah I don't know which airline were
playing but we're not playing the same
one please yeah technically any country
doesn't believe they live days just
Grantham France s the days it's not the
same Japanese kind of the day it's like
its own separate think it's like the
toilet to sink and then a bad day that's
weird
you know remember yeah you peed in it
I remember you peed in it and Brent no
baby that's not a toilet that's of the
day oh I really remember ash though it
was then it was me assuming yourself no
it was the first hotel or air B&B that
we stayed in when we were planning the
wedding oh that Oh anyway
[Music]
all right so it found his hand trip if
you don't come eat it you're on oh it's
just a month right now that I'm filming
this I'm it's like torture because I
cannot wait learning about much of this
during this trip I get so much of beer
[Music]
much is really craving this for the last
four years I've been craving this so
badly that I ordered some from Amazon
like the instant noodle time that's like
it's you're on branded just not the same
oh my god I also have to mention by the
way it took us about 40 minutes to get
here from our hotel in Universal Studio
see it all the way over here because
this the closest each Iran has in the
city so taking the trains and then it
was so funny because we got out at the
wrong stop and so we had to wait for the
next train and we thought it was one
stopover and then we got off there and
it wasn't it was still one more stopover
so it took extra long to get here oh but
we're here we're enjoying this
amazing
that's a huge takoyaki this street is so
interesting like every single time has
to be popping out like in Universal
CityWalk it's really weird but really
cool same time that's a huge hand over
there was sushi right there
[Music]
I got you cuz you were dancing didn't I
cut you anyway yeah takoyaki whoo all
right so we came to check out a memo
sheep I think that's a pronounced it
cafe
[Music]
so cute hi cutie no I'm a bit you okay
you get it oh of course you my girls are
so tiny aren't they cute it's adorable
you're kind of nervous of that one huh
they said that the white dog doesn't
like kids you're vicious aren't you
following me
whoa they've nip it here a little bit
yeah be careful
[Music]
Frandsen
[Music]
I love the herd
[Music]
[Music]
it's a sign of dominance when they do
that through this guy
dang pin him down whoa whoa the black
ones trying to show dominance over the
little brown one I'm gonna pitch you
come over here
stop being dominant stop being dominant
what you have to do is face though oh
damn they really like to play rough man
are you sure you want to get one of
these dogs they pretty violent
true but oh no man imagine we brought
one of these homes they would attack the
cats like crazy
[Music]
all right today we are at Universal
Studios in Osaka Japan yeah we're so
used to butchering everyone else's like
culture and heritage with our theme
parks and restaurants it's always cool
to go to other countries and see how
they reinterpret America and like
butcher our culture all right so today
we are at Universal Studios Osaka Japan
and we're all a bit under the weather
we're gonna push through this enjoy our
official like last day in Japan and
tomorrow we're off to curry go
[Music]
honestly I think they did a really good
job reinterpreting America at least
Hollywood they did a good job get the
palm trees how the landmark restaurants
and house they have our grocery store -
it's pretty crazy it's really cool so
Isaac you read all the books all the
Harry Potter but and I promised you that
once you finish reading all the book
that I will take you to Universal
Studios and we could check out Harry
Potter world yeah but unfortunately our
schedule about really really busy and so
we weren't able to fulfill that promise
right away so it's pretty cool that now
the first time he gets to see Harry
Potter world is in Japan how do you feel
about that baby that's exciting
yeah look at this puppet and hugging me
the rule here now is I must speak in a
British accent all the time so we leave
Harry Potter world
[Music]
Hogwarts Express baby I'm so excited for
you cool look at this what does it say
fold again hug me hug me dude you're in
cloud clean in Japan butter beer
I'll bite the first round look at this
oh my gosh isn't so cute right there
butter beer straight ahead
a tiny Dukes honeydukes what do they
sell here this is where they have the
jelly beans huh cool look at the
butterbeer let me see let me take a
photo
oh cool
have you seen this wizard Harry Harry
have you seen the wizard just getting
good I know Sirius Black when they were
it when he was being framed huh yeah but
he's a good guy see Elias I know that
much aren't you proud of me go check out
honeydukes
oh wait let's look for daddy we don't
want to go too far away let's go honey
look baby look at the stairs behind you
they're so cute
honey do you you have one of these on
Uncle Carrie got it for you look at the
chocolate frogs I remember because our a
twin the in the first movie yeah I
remember that too yes so many cool
little thing oh my god Oh cute
look at this Amy's little jelly bean
jelly slugs chocolate one chocolate
everything oh no what the pumpkin juice
tastes like I really taste like really
bad
oh really like they would spit up
[Music]
in the hospital three rows
really is this pumpkin flavored juice
cocktail from concentrate cute what do
they do you only get a glimpse of them
for like five seconds oh really and now
you can actually hold one oh yeah butter
beer really everything ladies don't
forget to take a picture of your butt
butter beer yeah baby go for it Cheers
[Music]
is it good
you take it drink it a little bit and
then let Daddy make a massage
[Music]
[Music]
now this is what I'm talking about
look at that I know isn't it awesome
payments with credit cards available
yeah this woldemar one is cool you
choose the dark side and the light side
the light my God where am i sorry wrong
franchise and he actually responded
though he sort of like said it used to
be what do you choose I mean I'm not a
wand experts are no me neither
dragonglass he's not like such a dad by
the way with all these like wrong
references
[Music]
what are you looking at Hogwarts that's
so cool I love how I am just excited as
excited as I think even though I don't
read the books but I did see all the
movies this is so I love when things
from a movie or a book come to real life
because and it just feels amazing it
feels like oh my gosh it's actually here
like I'm literally right here in front
of my eyes look at that it's that's
their sigil did you know that my dad
hogs with wings
you ready to go to school Isaac first
year wizard your first year Harry all
right hey you're about to go you are
Harry man you got the glasses and
everything you're just missing the scarf
we're inside huh no it's dark in here
ding I don't think this camera is
capturing it get some dark in here my
eyeballs could barely see
oh man at the Japanese that definitely
would
that's Hermione's Japanese boys
La Nina look at that you're nice and dry
Isaac decided not to get on the dressing
ride with us so we got so it's cold now
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
no you're gonna wait in line with us and
then leave through the exit for that
wood to clear all right it's lunchtime
here in Jurassic Park we're dining by in
actual losses from the Jurassic time a
dinosaur egg that you have cracked look
at how cute Isaac Isaac little meal is
he wanted to get the kids meal and it's
so cute and tiny extra eyes that a false
yeah it's a fossil cookie look at how
cute this is minions part
medium part right I decided to get tiny
little petite waffles all shaped like
minions it's a waffle so adorable
[Music]
like Universal Studios version of
toontown look Bank of evil haha
you're taller than two minions put
together now you're a big kid now look
at this there's a tutor they call him to
[ __ ] throughout the duration of the
day I feel like I'm slowly losing my
voice I feel like by tomorrow I'm not
gonna have a voice which is not good so
I need my voice for Korea for our
anniversary
oh yeah tomorrow's anniversary dude I
can't believe it's been seven years
how'd you like our day at Universal
Studios Japan
[Music]
[Music]